and finally new rule conspiracy theories
have to go back to what they used to be
fun little stories we would tell each
other when we were high space aliens
crashed in Roswell Hitler escaped to
Argentina Elvis is alive and working at
the IHOP
that's what conspiracy theories used to
be but now there the ideology of the
Republican Party conspiracy theorists
used to be called crazy now they're
called senator it used to be an
unwritten rule of both parties that you
can't just make [ __ ] up the old you're
entitled to your own opinion but not
your own facts thing but that was before
Republicans discovered yes yes you can
just make [ __ ] up you can have your own
facts in fact we just pulled a fresh
batch out of the oven and by the oven I
mean our ass
you know
I never liked rush limbaugh but I would
take a return to 90s era ditto heads any
day because it turned out that rush was
really just a gateway drug to which they
eventually built up a tolerance and then
needed something stronger that was Glenn
Beck which led to Alex Jones and now
Republicans here the Alex Jones party
there was literally nothing too stupid
and conspiratorial that you will not
swallow Hillary running a child sex ring
out of a pizza parlor sounds right
Obama's birth certificate fake Jade helm
absolutely
Trump Tower the crazier it gets the more
they like it that's their Jam they
believe anything so we can stop sending
reporters to diners now to figure them
out they're not there for the breakfast
they literally think there are clouds in
the coffee this week we found out that
83% of Republicans either definitely
believe or are unsure whether five
million people voted illegally in the
last election
something Trump just completely made up
even appointed a voter fraud Commission
based on his own fraud hey you remember
that [ __ ] I made up I want you to
get to the bottom of it
this isn't about ideology anymore Trump
has none anyway when he decided to run
he didn't brush up on conservativism by
studying Buckley and Reagan and his only
experience with Goldwater was in a
Russian hotel room
and this isn't about actual Republicans
either those guys are gone George Bush
the first quit the NRA in 1995 when some
gun nuts called the Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms jackbooted thugs
Bush said it deeply offended his sense
of decency and honor but when Alex Jones
says children faked their own deaths at
Sandy Hook it doesn't deter Trump from
telling him your reputation is amazing
I'll not I will not let you down they're
soul mates you say twisted crap to crazy
people so do I we should grab a [ __ ]
sometime
the latest thing Trump pulled out of his
ass is this nonsense about the FBI
spying on him
there was no spy it was just the neuro
checking out whether someone on the
Trump campaign was communicating with
Russia based on the tiny fact that
everybody in the Trump campaign was
communicating with Russia
it's what the FBI does investigation
it's in their name
[Applause]
even the folks who believe that the
world is secretly run by an alien race
of shape-shifting lizard people they
have a video to back it up
[Applause]
can't argue with that
but Spygate there's literally nothing
and that is so alarming because one way
we measure the health of a society is by
how conspiratorial it is communist
countries Arab dictatorships those
places you could always say sell
anything because there was no trust in
the institutions Republicans that's what
you're doing to this country and so the
only answer is that more sane people
have to vote than insane people in every
election so so tell tell your same
friends that the midterms are the most
important election of their lives and
tell your conservative friends that
climate scientists are working with the
Clintons
to slip a chemical into the air ducts at
polling places that will turn everyone
who votes gay